[Applause]
explain something to me because you've
been the biggest vanderbilt fan
yeah okay you did you didn't go to the
yeah
you i know you've worked that out in
your head yeah go
we don't get that in new york like
because we don't have college sports
right so we've never
got to before the records for a little
bit when they did good i was there
we did yeah well rutgers was having like
a really good year and then i remember
everybody's like oh everybody's cheering
for rutgers and you're like y'all just
heard about rutgers new yorkers were
caring about a new jersey
rutgers was had a great season when i
was there
and so that's and it was like kind of
like oh six their games are
708 yeah yeah their games were kind of
on tv more so then everybody's like oh
this is here
ray rice yeah and then so wow and so and
so people were kind of excited about
that they don't care
about it none of my boys maybe it's
different because i grew up in like
manhattan or
whatever but me we never discussed
college sports at all right i didn't
even know college sports
i knew it was popular because i like
heard about march madness and these
things
we didn't watch march madness yeah i
know this sounds probably crazy
never once growing up did me and my boys
go yo we want to watch the games this
saturday with march madness
didn't watch a single college basketball
game until i was in college yeah
and my this our school made the
tournament the year before i went to
ucsb
and then i saw what the [ __ ] this thing
was so break down
the like the leap between
i'm gonna i don't go to the school but i
love the school
i identify with the school how does that
work
so it's it's it's it's not just the
south but it's like also the midwest
like
like ohio state all over the country
it's just new york that they don't do it
uh it's it's you know a lot of us didn't
have pro sports
so nashville didn't have pro teams we
didn't have the titans uh
so everybody's like really into college
because that's all you can really root
for alabama
what pro team is in alabama so it's a no
if there's no pro team you just love the
sport and that's the only opportunity
yeah so it's like and you you know it's
that town you're it's kind of
it's more of about the town and stuff
like that so we didn't have the titans
growing up
so a lot of my friends were university
of tennessee fans
but i was a vanderbilt fan which was in
nashville yeah and vanderbilt's like
was notoriously struggling a lot back
then
and so no one was a fan of vanderbilt
then uh
but i always think it's good to be a fan
of like a team that struggles like it
makes
builds character like you have to like
you don't just get handy you're not the
yankee you know i remember lebron
perfect night
lebron was like a band-aid lebron was
like a perfect kid like for his age that
he grew up in there he listed his
favorite teams it was the
cowboys yankees and maybe the bulls or
something you're like oh was it
was it that was that hard struggle of
just all of those teams won
yeah didn't they have a nice struggle in
his life just want some wins
but i'm saying like it's there was a big
generation of that where like
people were fans of like teams that were
like there was no
they don't even know what it was like to
lose yeah like you know that's like if
you're a patriots fan or red sox but
before they all started winning
yeah like when you if you a long time
ago you struggled dude like
and then if you're like a kid you're
like oh i don't know we've never not
won yeah like that's all we've ever
dealt with if you're a boston
sports fan that's our age you don't know
not winning
oh yeah you remember a few years because
the celtics weren't good in the 90s
patriots were all a joke yeah and then
the red sox never cursed yeah yeah
yeah i grew up in dallas so the first
three years i started
watching football four years we won
three super bowls so i was like oh this
is what it is
this is yeah and then now i'm like man
[ __ ] i would appreciate that if it
happened now yeah so i do think that's
true also one thing helps you
college is culturally it's a part of the
south it's almost like i remember being
like
i guess i gotta root for a college team
i just want to do it
and then i'll try to go to that college
yeah and then when i didn't go there i
gave up but it's just
it's just like sports is so central to
life football in particular
yeah you got to find a team that's going
to be lovely these colleges that would
never let us in
yeah we just care about the sports man
like they
uh like you ride your whole life for the
school you buy the merch
oh yeah and then all of a sudden you're
like i'd like to go and continue my
education there and then they go
you're not good enough
that's insane how do you still root well
there's not a college in america that
would have let me in like so
like i mean what am i you know like i
went to a community college and then
for a year no credits one year
and then i did western kentucky for a
semester again
zero credits felt bold i felt bowling
and i'm actually a pretty good bowler
but like once they made me keep the
score on my they're like you gotta write
the score down you're like i don't know
how to do that dude like
that's why they all have the screens
they keep it for you yeah and the guy's
like now you got to learn how to do it
and i'm like i don't care like and then
that was it i didn't i didn't learn
but that was so i could never get in
these colleges anyway but you don't have
any
you just want to root for something like
we didn't have baseball teams we were
the closest was like the braves yeah uh
for baseball so that's because they were
always on uh tnt right
yeah it's only like two hours from
nashville or tb yeah it's real close
yeah a lot of people be cubs fans
because they were on wgn yeah and so
what you could see that's why the
cowboys they were always on tv so
everybody became a big fan of them
yeah uh but yeah you i don't know you
just
you like these college teams you the
older you get though the more it changes
because it's crazy because at first
you're like
these kids are older than you yeah and
then you like become older
then you're like dude i mean i could
have that kid
and then and it's weird to be so like
you're
i love them but you're you learn to like
kind of back off to be like i can't you
can't admire
mad at an 18 year old like you know a
young 18 years
you're like i'm furious at this kid yeah
you know i used to follow him on twitter
if someone was thinking about going to
vanderbilt i'd follow him on twitter
and then when they didn't i would
unfollow
[Laughter]
17. he's a 17 year old kid like in here
and you're not it was weird enough to be
honest oh it's crazy
it's inappropriate a little bit it's a
little so you're recruiting you're
trying to recruit them together yeah
look if we had some crazy kid coming to
vanderbilt i would definitely follow him
i know a lot of the golfers now because
they're at that thing and i'll follow
them
uh but then some of them i know but it's
like sometimes
yeah you follow them and then you're
like yeah it's an 18 year old dude like
i don't
whatever they're posting you're like i
don't care about any of this stuff
[Applause]
you